Junction objects are useful when you want to have a
many to many relationship. You've seen one to many
relationships already, with festivals and attendees. In fact, you
could say that a festival can have many attendees.
But you wouldn't necessarily say an attendee can have
many festivals. Then we got to this situation with
stages and bands. Once. One stage can have multiple
bands, and one band can not play at multiple stages.
This is a many-to-many relationship. To make
this relationship happen, we needed to create
the set time junction object. Now let's
think back to Facebook, who uses Salesforce
to manage some of their hiring processes.
I'm going to give you a few situations,
and I want you to tell me which ones would require a junction object?